all right welcome back to the special
edition of Hannity one of the many
scandals surrounding the Biden family is
Joe Biden's refusal to acknowledge what
is his seventh grandchild which is
finally making headlines the media has
finally caught up to us but still being
ignored by many on the left here's what
Congressman Eric swalwall told Fox News
digital when asked about the Scandal was
do you think the President should
acknowledge Him for a child I'll leave
your personal family matters to you and
I'll leave the president's Family
Matters to him oh just Family Matters
yeah I'm sure he'd say the same thing
about Trump anyway here with reaction
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
Victor Davis Hanson you know I know in
light of cocaine at the White House and
I know in light of the Biden family
Syndicate and all the revelations we're
finding out about and the sweetheart
deal that Hunter got maybe this doesn't
seem like a big deal for people uh
Victor Davis Hansen it's a big deal this
four-year-old little girl the
circumstances surrounding a bird should
mean nothing
this is her her biological grandfather
is the president
to me it's just cruel your take
yeah I agree with you I mean usually we
we leave we leave these to be private
matters but the bidens were very
different with Hunter Biden Sean when
you had a Don Nixon or Roger Clinton or
Malik Obama that had these problems they
were kept away from the White House and
so Hunter was not kept away he was
brought into the Inner Circle and
therefore his own problems became part
of the presidency and Biden then the
Biden trademark as we hear from Joe was
the Biden family solidarity that if you
were remember we were told that the word
of abiding is solid gold so we were
heard Biden family Biden family Biden
family well this this poor girl is a
member of the Biden family and so they
brought this issue into the White House
by bringing hunter in and then we have
the other element that left always
lectures on the children Nancy Pelosi
couldn't finish his sentence that were
doing this for the children we were the
party who cares about the innocent and
vulnerable children well this is an
archetypal case there's a girl who
didn't choose her father or her mother
she came into this world as a human
being and and she's got a father and
it's time for Joe Biden to acknowledge
that fact and to to extend the
supposedly traditional Biden support the
Biden family solidarity should include a
granddaughter
yeah you know and the same guy that said
they're all our kids talking about kids
and actually no parents are are the lead
for in terms of instilling moral values
in their children values that they
believe in in my view that's their role
so we've been watching and it's a theme
I brought up all week now we're hearing
from staffers and leaks about Biden's
vicious temper Maureen Dowd USA Today
they write about this child and the
outrage of it but only the within the
last week then we hear the story about
drugs in the white house but there were
two prior incidents my question is I'm
beginning to see a pattern emerge of
Democrats wanting to push this man out
and not have him run in 2024. am I wrong
no you're absolutely right and that
would solve a lot of problems because it
gets rid of the Kamala Harris problems
but I would add one qualifier Sean
they're leaking things that are pretty
much impeachable offenses if they were
true in the case of the corruption and
they're leaking things about cognitive
disabilities that would naturally
warrant a 25 25th amendment
investigation but notice they stopped
there and they stopped there because
these leaks are intended to ensure that
Joe Biden is not going to run in an
imperil their chances in 2024 but they
want him to finish out this term because
they do not want Camilla Harris so a lot
of this is in Maine aimed at Camilla
Harris
tell us the downside of Joe Biden so he
doesn't run and we get somebody besides
Camilla Harris in 2024 but not to the
extent that they're actionable worries
that would uh attenuate the Biden term
and give us kamela Harris so I think
that's what's behind it exit question
what are the odds Joe and Kamal Harris
are on the ticket for the Democrats in
November of 2024.
I would say about 25 percent
wow he's declining Sean at a at a
geometric rate not arithmetically he's
one fall one slip away from ending his
presidency so I don't see how it's I
don't see how he's going to be able to
do that and I think I've been making
I've been saying the same thing first
multiplier of that reality
to to have Victor Davis Hansen say what
I'd been saying he's one fall major fall
away from Bay and kicked off I feel
really good about myself because you're
one of the smartest guys I know so
Victor we love having you thank you my
friend hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else